[Music]
I think that we ought to change our
Town's slogan a great place to call home
is confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to as home we need a crosswalk on
Trent Avenue between Frost and Allegheny
and also
[Music]
oh my our UFO has crashed my backyard
has taken out my azaleas and destroyed
my bird bath and
like that it makes me
just say UFO
Chris what is that you remember the
spaceship this is the little man who
came out of it he's got to be a secret
don't tell anybody
she shouldn't know we gotta trust if
there's nothing else we can do you could
kill her kill me
I'll kill you that's what I'll do
it you think we can call them Jewels
he's not Jules he's more of a Gary your
dad was in here earlier he said he was
buying apples for an alien like an
illegal alien
thank you for the picture he hands them
to me all the time maybe he's trying to
tell you something
I'm worried what you have said has not
been normal I'm okay how can you can you
say that when you're buying apples for
[Music]
the government is searching for a
security satellite that crashed any
moment we waste is a moment they can
discover him you're seeing the movies
you know what happens to the eyes when
they fall to Earth
[Music]
Jules has come to me quite a bit to us
it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien
they're coming
bus four hanging out together we got
along pretty well we're so thankful for
you
[Music]
what the
thank you
[Music]